five of Jeffrey Epstein's accusers say
they are outraged that Prince Andrew is
allegedly providing zero cooperation
Epstein's sex trafficking case here in
the u.s. Andrew who was Epstein's
longtime friend said in November
interview he is willing to help
investigators provided his lawyers agree
Virginia goo Frey claims that Epstein
pressured her to have sex with Andrew
when she was just 17 Andrew as you know
denies that this latest twist in the
case comes just weeks after Prince Harry
and his wife Megan made their stunning
decision to give up their royal duties
and most prestigious titles in their
search for privacy while Roy Anika is in
her tenth year covering the Royals she's
a royal correspondent for The Sunday
Times in London she's here to sort it
all out well you're never bored in your
job I could say that let's start with
Andrew because US authorities at a news
conference the other day an unprecedent
and said Andrew has provided zero
cooperation after that debacle of an
interview were you surprised that he
that Andrew apparently is not
cooperating after he said he would I
have to say I'm not really that's price
Gail and I've seen the reports overnight
that Andrews saying actually you know
this isn't true I will provide you no
testimony if I'm asked to he said they
said no one had reached out to them yet
I says that's not true she's absolutely
not true in actually Gloria al reg who
as you know represents quite a few of
the victims provided my newspaper with a
letter she had sent to Andrew in early
December we ran the story asking him to
provide sworn testimony the FBI so
that's just not correct he has been
approached is he so held in high regard
with the Queen and the other members of
the family he certainly held in very
high regard by the Queen you know she
sticks by him we saw her out riding with
my daughter's break we saw her at church
with him last week I would say amongst
the rest of the family whilst he's still
very much part of the family I think
there is a growing frustration that this
story continues to bubble and seemingly
Prince Andrews lack of cooperation
seemingly keeps providing that clip fuel
no how it go ahead you spoke with Prince
Charles last week did how is he dealing
with both Prince Andrew and with what's
happening with Harry and Megan well I
mean the Prince of Wales I interviewed
him in Davos at the World Economic Forum
he you know he played a very integral
role in that Sandringham summit he was
very key with the Queen with William and
Harry and Meaghan negotiating that deal
I think was no doubt you know
swales understands he's been through the
mill himself over the years knows all
about you know the press and and the
restrictions of that role but uh you
know ultimately Harry has his son Megan
is dorchen or he wants them to be happy
but there is no doubt Prince whales and
William and the Queen are really sad
about what's happened so in a regular
family you're in the family and that's
it families family but in the royal
family you can step away from a senior
role and now there's talk of Prince
Charles wanting to streamline the
families I mean they're gonna be layoffs
while the Prince of Wales had this
vision which he sort of he debuted the
golden Diamond Jubilee in 2012 of a
streamline monarchy yeah he's very
keenly aware that in order to stay
relevant the morning the modern monarchy
has to seem to be you know working you
know for a purpose yeah but for him that
streamline monarchy always was going to
include Harry and whomever he chose to
be his wife so he'll be readjusting
quickly there were reports not long ago
that the Queen would step down and hurts
Charles would become king but that's not
going to happen it's not going to happen
the Queen took a vow the rest of her
life she's not going to abdicate all
right Roy Anika thank you very much